I know that you are working with Ryan
Reynolds I'm working yeah so Ryan
approached me about uh doing directing a
John Candy documentary right and uh I I
wanted to talk about this because John
Candy was one of my comedy heroes yes I
grew up watching SCTV and uh so many
people know him from uh trains planes
automobiles or Uncle Buck or
um Splash but you know I I really saw
him on SCTV and was just enchanted with
this guy and I had the opportunity to
spend some time with him when I was in
college oh wow I orchestrated uh
basically a scam to get John Candy to
come and visit the uh the Lampoon
building oh wow and I got to go and get
him
um and chauffeur him around and I got to
spend about a day and a half with him I
think and it was magical because he was
he taught me a lesson he was everything
I wanted John Candy to be in person and
you know sometimes that's not the case
yeah you know majority of times a
majority of times you idolize someone
you think they're great and you meet
them and they're not that person and and
it's not their fault they're projecting
something that we all like and then we
want them to be that he was that times
10. he was yeah the John Candy that I
was hoping he would be times ten and he
was great and I remembered uh talking to
him
pretty late at night having a chat with
him and he asked me what I was thinking
of doing and I said I might like to try
comedy and he looked like through me
like into my eyes and he said he said
kid a lot yeah like like Johnny LaRue
like Hey kid and he said kid you don't
try comedy you do it because you have to
oh and I walked away from that thinking
he's right I mean if I'm in I'm all in
there's no trying it and huh that's this
isn't going this isn't working out I
think I'll we'll take the LSAT yeah
um uh instead you're like actually I
will take this LSD and just make jokes
instead right exactly yeah my God what
the lsats were you gonna be a lawyer oh
that was my my fab and it still is my
fault what kind of lawyer well I'm just
whatever lawyer Kim Kardashian is that's
what I'm gonna do she's a lawyer and I'm
a lawyer don't give up on your secondary
dream
yeah that's the most inspirational thing
never give up on your fallback yeah you
don't try to be a Kim Kardashian lawyer
never stop checking that scene that's
what Kim Kardashian would probably say
to me I said you know sometimes I think
I might try being alert you don't try
being a lawyer slash owner of the Spanx
Empire
sorry sorry did I say yeah it's skims
are they different of course they're
different they're two completely
different brands but I mean they both
Pepsi and Coke okay okay look everyone's
on me I know what no I'm asking I made a
mistake I made a mistake it is it's two
different brands of like you know
getting it in is there is there hey can
I ask a quick question also well did we
just come up with a different term for
pornography as well getting it what is
this
getting it right getting it tight yeah
yeah yeah is there a that's the that's
that's trademark that is that well it's
Erica Brown is always saying she works
she works here and she pretty much runs
everything here at the Conan Empire and
Erica Brown who who is the queen she
says get it right get it tight yeah um
my question is is there a skims slash
Spanx for men I think there is yeah yeah
because I would like that
oh it's just it's me wearing there's
just male Spanx there's male Spanx oh
yeah yeah are there male skims I'm sure
there are yeah I guess okay
well it's a little late now it's a
podcast you don't need them now I do I
know there's some video here I hate to
break it to you but there's some videos
why do you say it so conspiratorially or
kind of sexually like well because you
know I have those weighted blankets yeah
and it makes people feel the idea of me
being held closely all day oh is this
your face you're right and nice
various areas uh oh stop various areas
buy them for you what's that you have to
go and do that I can't go you have to go
you're my assistant I couldn't do that
you have to go and say I'm here to buy
some skim slash Spanx for Conan O'Brien
hold on we've got we've got verification
verification no male skims yeah
let's get this out to the Kardashians no
no
the Kardashians yeah you you create a
brand yeah oh my God lawyering and you
do this spanking I have to mention this
I think we may have mentioned this
before but it just cracks me up you know
there's a lot of celebrities out there
and Ryan Reynolds one he's got a like an
aviator gin I believe I've got a company
called Hank's kerchief yes
not only that my jacket is literally
lined with a hank structure that's cool
line it's got the little logo and
everything you know what I love
did you want to sell handkerchiefs or
did you have to because of the names I
wanted to say what were the other
options I wanted to sell I wanted to
sell kerchiefs I I wanted to sell
kerchiefs and then as I was sitting
there about four minutes after I thought
of the idea I burst out laughing because
I thought of the name and so many people
there was one group of people that were
like no you you really shouldn't do that
that that's hard to pronounce and I said
it's easy Hanks kerchiefs and they're
like no people are gonna think it's
hankster Chiefs and I'm like you just
said it not a problem yeah that's not a
problem because
I didn't know
and I thought that you didn't want to
but because it fits your name
you have to do O'Brien's potatoes I do
yeah or whatever you know yeah I you
want to know what oh Brian's potatoes do
you like potatoes Conan
I can't have them they make me better
you
uh so no you eat so many potatoes and
then you need your special uh Conan
O'Brien Spanx yeah exactly exactly uh
well anyway market demand you do Spanx
but just call them straight up Hanks
yeah
listen I will listen I will
I will invest in the company okay I
think that you are the front man for the
we call them Hanks and uh it is male
Spanx
um they can't sue you because that's
your name you've had that your entire
life that is true and uh I will be an
investor I also want to be in on the
design great I have a lot of ideas about
where it should hug and hold okay
you
don't understand when you say it we are
then forced to think about it you know
what I mean and visualize it I'm
visualizing it and I'm telling you we're
doing this we're doing it thanks we're
doing it we can't release this podcast
until we've you know oh trust me this is
never going to be released okay good
yeah yeah I mean but anyway back to what
we were saying I I'm so glad that you're
doing this documentary on John Candy
because he was important to me I mean
I'm sure you're going to but people like
Marty Short they have great stories oh
all I mean all of them I I'm actually
most excited about the ability to be
able to talk to as many people that John
worked with and was close with because
everybody sort of feels the same
yeah there's not there's not really
anybody who goes that son of a [ __ ] I
hated that guy like he really truly is a
complete outlier because there is not a
soul on Earth that didn't believe John
Candy in that you know hey I always
believed him in you know whatever I saw
him in he was the guy that was
just as lethal in a supporting role as
he was in a lead role you know I mean he
could be the polka you know king of you
know the Midwest and just kill for you
know two or three scenes but he could
also be Uncle Buck you know and he
really was just you know and and by the
way you know he would go off and make
these you know he's part of that
generation because I I really look at
you know SCTV and and SNL that being
like the first
like young second graduating class of of
TV comedy that then you saw graduate and
matriculate over time and get into
movies and yet he would go off and do
these big movies and yet there's also
like a handful of Canadian films I've
never seen that he went and did because
he would always go back home and and do
Canadian he had like a big farm yeah
yeah yeah
um and so he there's just this wealth of
of of stuff out there and he was just so
great in everything and what makes it so
tragic is that well I mean there's a lot
of things that that make it tragic but
like he really was on the cusp I think
of becoming like a really
beloved dramatic actor yeah and I and I
think he was like one role away from
that actually really becoming the the
case because he the blueprint is all
there I remember very clearly
uh started my talk show in uh uh
September of 1993
and I'm on set
um because I used to always think one of
the people I can't wait to have on is
John Candy because that's going to like
close the loop
the enemy and I'll be able to tell him
remember I talked to you oh of course
years ago and you told me this and here
I am
and I remembered someone coming in and
we were in rehearsal and someone told us
that John Candy had passed away and I
just deflated I was just you know uh and
couldn't believe it because it's such a
loss he did a sketch he was in a sketch
an SCTV sketch that's one of them that
seared my brain it seared my brain there
was a sketch it was a promo for a
television show a western called yellow
belly
and
um and John Candy plays yellow belly and
the whole song is he's such a coward
it's like yellow belly the coward and
he's so he's dressed as this uh sort of
Cavalry Soldier and he's shaking and
quaking and he's afraid and he's walking
down the street and a woman and her
daughter like wearing bonnets walk by
and the daughter I think I'm getting
this wrong I'm sure but what I remember
is the daughter sort of whispering to
the mom like Mom who is that man and she
goes shunny it's yellow belly and John
Candy
turns and shoots them both in the back
oh my God
1977 in in Rhode Island in Misquamicut
Rhode Island at my grandfather's house
huddled around a black and white TV and
my mind exploded through my skull that
you could do that and then the song goes
I was like I remember Hulk in the gamma
rays origin seriously no I mean that the
idea was so wrong and so funny and he
was so good in it uh and so when I
finally got to meet him I just said I'm
sorry yellow bell and he's like
chuckled chuckled about yellow belly oh
that's amazing uh but well I'd love to
talk with you for the doc I make no
promises that you'll make the cut but
as long as you meet my fee yes I'll meet
your fee I will all the brown M M's I've
read the content I've read the contract